hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast accessories and techniques for
FTIR sample analysis is presented by
Richard Larsen PhD a senior product
specialist at spectral consulting I am
Judy O'Rourke of lab routes and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinth
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want anytime you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box it
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Larson I will
now turn the presentation over to him
Thank You Julie and thank the audience
for being able to attend today I greatly
appreciate it the discussion today is
basically how to get more out of your
instrumentation and there's a lot of
different wavelengths that effect a
molecule so all molecules absorb energy
in a lot of different ways different
wavelengths of light each contribute to
information about the molecule in terms
of structure composition or the
electronic configuration of the molecule
infrared or mid infrared as its termed
is a very narrow range of that
wavelength stream and you can see the
rainbow of colors up on the top here but
you're talking about a very
range from about 2500 nanometers which
is 4000 wave numbers to 25000 nanometers
which is 400 wave numbers the reciprocal
centimeter or wave number Singh notation
is specifically for this particular
region of the spectrum and it was done
so that you worked with whole numbers
you discussed whole numbers instead of
2500 point six five three or things like
that or the numbers got extremely large
like twenty five twenty four thousand
five hundred and sixty one something
like that so it's just a convenience for
us in the industry can use those
wavelength values so in infrared
spectroscopy where FTIR incident white
light interacts with all the vibrational
modes of the molecule as it continues to
vibrate all those little atoms that are
that are attached by molecular bonds are
moving in different directions and they
absorb energy from the source and on the
other side of the sample what we get is
missing lines basically the molecules
that has absorbed some of that light
data and if we compare the light before
the molecule and after the molecule we
can actually see a difference in the
spectrum and what we see is an
absorption spectrum that is
characteristic for that particular
molecule so as the molecule vibrates in
this case we're looking at a molecule of
water where oxygen is the red atom in
the center and the two little hydrogen
atoms are on either end and it's
continuously vibrating moving in
different directions and when there's
changes in that vibration there's
actually a very small change in the
polarizability the oxygen is slightly
negative the oxygens are slightly
positive or sorry the hydrogen's are
slightly positive excuse me
and that polarizability changes a little
bit as the molecule stretches and bends
and we need that interaction along with
the light absorption to see the infrared
spectrum
because what happens is there's an
absorption process that occurs and this
is the energy levels in the quantum
values and we're looking at changes
between the V 0 V 1 levels which is the
vibrational modes the larger excited
states that we see up at the top has to
do with the in the UV vis absorption
which we're not going to discuss in this
presentation so we're talking about
these little energy gaps where the
molecules transit transitioning between
the ground vibrational state and the
first vibrational state or in the
overtone modes from V 1 to V 2 and
sometimes we start off at V 1 and go
down to the zero and that's an emission
mode so we've talked about all the
little things that do happen when we
look at the vibrational modes associated
with infrared absorption so what we end
up getting is we see that this little
oxygen and hydrogen amalgam called the
water we have symmetric stretches
anti-symmetric stretches and the bending
modes and when we look at that in the
infrared spectrum we see the O H
stretches all mashed together here
because they're so strong and they're so
intense and then the O expands at
another wavelength value and this is
very specific to water so if we change
one of the atoms in the in the hydrogen
from hydrogen to deuterium the spectrum
would change completely there would be
additional information because we have
Oh H and O in stretching and o H
spending and OD stretching in an OD
bending so it would be two more Peaks
that would be added to the spectrum this
information here is actually an overtone
mode so when we look at something that's
a little bit more complex like isopropyl
alcohol or isopropanol we see a lot more
activity in the spectrum so just like we
saw in the previous spectrum we have the
O H stretch here right about 30
the CH can ch3 stretching modes that are
right around 3000 the CH and ch3 bending
modes that are below 1500 but above 1000
and then the carbon carbon and carbon
oxygen stretching modes and the co h
Bend and there's other bending modes
that are involved in this as well for
the carbon carbon and carbon oxygen we
go to something like benzo nitrile we
have more activity and in this case the
arm the benzine CH stretch because
they're all the same we only get one v
instead of the multiple piece that we
saw for isopropanol the carbon nitrogen
the triple bond carbon nitrogen stretch
is all by itself out there about 20 to
50 and that's the only thing that really
gives a band in that area we have the
ring breathing modes carbon hydrogen
bending and carbon carbon stretching and
carbon carbon bends so it's a fairly
simple molecule but there's a lot of
activity because there's a lot of atoms
in that particular molecule so as I said
before every time we look at a molecule
we get different activity different
absorption modes or absorption Peaks
based on the different functional groups
that are present in the molecule and one
thing to note is that if we have benzene
ring CH stretches they're generally
above 3000 wave numbers and the
aliphatic or straight chain CH stretches
are below 3000 wave numbers there's
another co see stretch right about 2250
same as that that's a nitrile the C
triple bond n and then we have the HOH
then the M and one and two bands for
proteins carbonyls are right around 1750
benzene rings we see some things there
and so on down the line the idea is is
that as we become more accustomed to
looking at our spectra we start to
recognize certain functional groups and
say yes I have an alcohol so I should
see a very strong right wideband above
3000 and I have an avid band and I
should see some activity around 14 to
1500 those are the types of things that
start to become implanted in your brain
as you keep working with the spectra
well we're not going to go into a
complete interpretation today but we're
going to talk more about the
capabilities of the infrared analysis
method so the biggest one is
identification and quantitation of
organic solid liquid or gas samples
infrared spectroscopy is one of the few
techniques that can give me exact
identification of a molecule especially
when I compare to a library of data I
can do analysis of powders solids gels
emulsions pastes pure liquid solutions
pure and mix the acids in front is used
for research methods development quality
control and quality assurance
applications among others and samples
can range in size from little fibers
only 20 microns in length to atmospheric
pollution studies involving fairly large
areas they set up cameras and detectors
across a quarter mile range to see if
there's a gas plume that's going across
a certain area just as an example of how
we do very large pollution studies lots
of different places that infrared is
used pharmaceutical research polymer
analysis environmental water quality
analysis QA and QC biochemical and
biomedical research and the list goes on
and on and every day there's new
discoveries that are made using infrared
spectroscopy beers law describes the
ability to do an analysis of
concentration because sample
concentration is directly related to the
infrared absorption intensity so the
capital a is the absorption intensity
the value of either peak height or peak
area equal to the absorption coefficient
for a specific infrared peak in a
specific sample the sample path length
how long
thick the sample is and the
concentration basically the coefficients
a and B fall out so we have a direct
correlation between capital A the
absorption intensity versus the sample
concentration and what we do is we plot
the concentration of the peak intensity
of the peak area versus the absorption
intensity starting to peak intensity
versity the concentration and we develop
a calibration curve like this where we
see that there's a fairly straight line
that can be drawn through all the
different points based on that peak
height to peak area so from that point
forward we could look at that particular
molecule whatever it is and say yes I
have a point three five moles present at
because my absorption intensity is about
point seven three so a good infrared
spectrum one of the criteria the
spectrum based on should be relatively
flat we don't want a lot of curvature or
a slant going off one way or the other
the highest transmission point should be
between 95 another percent T it can be a
little bit lower we certainly don't want
it above 110 percent or honored percent
T rather there should be fairly little
noise in the spectrum most FTIR
instrument says Fourier transform
infrared on the most common instrument
everybody works with will obtain a
sufficient signal-to-noise ratio or snr
within a minute of scanning a sample
anywhere from 16 to 64 scans depending
on the model and the configuration the
strongest band in the spectrum should be
greater than 50% T percent transmission
and should fall no lower than between 3
and 10 percent T because then we're
running into the problem of over-over
absorption where we're going beyond the
sensitivity of the detector and the last
comment air sample preparation is the
most important aspect of collecting a
useful in France spectrum so here is a
FTIR spectrum for a KBR pellet of
ibuprofen we have a flat level baseline
at about 100% good signal-to-noise ratio
our peak maximum is right around 10% not
greater than 5% and we got nice sharp
peaks with no interferences anywhere in
the spectrum look so the first technique
we're going to talk about is
transmission sampling transmission
analysis is the most common and most
universal method for analyzing the
solids liquids and gases that were
interested in transmission spectra have
the highest sensitivity and best
detection levels of all the inference
amping methods there's lots of different
documentary analytical methods and in
many cases it is the only recognized
analysis method transmission methods
include KBR pellets sample moles the use
of liquid or salt cells and thin films
of liquid and polymer samples and as a
graphic to illustrate all this we have
the KBR pellet technique where we mix
KBR powder and a satanist powdered
sample and then form it into a little
pellet the thin film technique where we
place a very thin amount or a small
amount of the sample onto a KBR plate
either dissolved inorganic solid let the
solvent dry off and create a thin film
or actually put a number another window
on top of that like this one where we
have a small amount of liquid trapped
between the two windows and then we also
have a solution technique where we can
put a solution or sample in a fixed path
length cell and get an analysis doing it
that way
the KBR pellet is the most recognized
method I think everybody that's ever
done undergraduate chemistry in organic
class has done it Kate mera pehla at
least I hope so because you learn a lot
trying to do that it's not the easiest
method but it gives you very good
sensitivity and once you've mastered the
ability to make a KBR pellet everything
else is much easier so there's lots of
you
USP and forensic analysis methods that
utilize KBR pellets for collection the
spectrum there's lots of different ionic
salts that can be used for this such as
sodium chloride potassium chloride or
cesium iodide but potassium bromine is
preferred these materials are very
moisture sensitive and you've got to
move quickly because if you've got a lot
of humidity in the in the laboratory
they'll they'll suck out humidity and
moisture right out of the air and become
wet and it can be a challenge if you
don't make use the proper procedure so
one thing that can go wrong is if you
don't collect your background spectrum
through the blank pellet holder you can
get what's called vignette increased
riksha of the beam and that can cause
wave number shifts or incomplete
compensation for the I'm certain water
beam so when you see the bottom spectrum
here in this figure you see a lot of
activity around three up above 3500 and
again around 1700 and then there's also
some stuff but clear and around 2250
that's because you're not getting good
compensation for the water and co2
that's naturally in the atmosphere
there's also some changes excuse me to
the spectrum that affects the quality of
the spectrum that you're getting so when
we look at the top spectrum we look we
ran the background with a 7mm millimeter
blank and we got a much better signal to
noise ratio spectrum and much better
quality of the spectrum by accounting
for the compensation of the beam
restriction so here we in completely
ground the sample or did an improper
pressing and what we see is this
severely sloping baseline the bass line
starts at about 60% T goes down to
almost zero and we see this large slope
associated with the spectrum and that
means that something is not quite right
and in this case we've got way too much
sample in this
in the spectrum in the scarring Hinda
Pella and so we see the slope again and
we see that the bands are touching very
near zero percent transmission and so
we've overloaded the pellet so to speak
we don't have clear distinct piece in
the spectrum so we doing a good
identification of what that material is
we also see a lot of overtone bands here
between 2000 and 3000 wave numbers
that's due to the intensity of the piece
down here and what's called the
fingerprint region so when we pressed a
good pellet we get a good spectrum that
looks just like this nice flat base line
again Peaks that are right around 10%
15% T nice sharp speaks no interference
piece due to the water the co2 it's just
a good spectrum overall Psalm all
samples is another technique that can
use your powers basically it's a mixture
of either in luge all mineral oil or
floral loop which is another good loop
material and a powdered sample the
powders mix put them all in a while and
then the mixture placed between the two
salt windows to collect the spectrum
generally moles are used for samples
that can exchange ionic components with
the KBR salt is also a simple and
inexpensive method for sample analysis
we need something quick neutral and
floor Lube low oils also have an
infrared spectrum it must be subtracted
from the small spectrum so basically
what we do is we collect a spectrum the
oil without the sample and use it as a
reference to do a subtraction
after all the spectra are collected
here's a case where we collected the
nujol oil separately and we have our
caffeine in the new job and we did the
subtraction and we just want to make
sure we mark the peaks not where the new
job was subtracted to make sure there's
no possible interference with the
caffeine spectrum other sampling
techniques include liquids so we use
liquid
with either water soluble or water
insoluble windows water soluble windows
of potassium bromine sodium chloride or
cesium iodide are very moisture
sensitive materials should be handled
carefully as they will quickly absorb
water or start to dissolve and so we
want to clean these windows very quickly
and we want to put them back into a
desiccator to keep them dry insoluble
windows such as barium fluoride or
calcium fluoride may not immediately
react with aqueous solutions but
eventually they can fog and reduce
throughput through the cell so again we
want to be very careful what types of
windows we're using with the type of
sample that we have if you suspect that
you have water in your sample or that
there might be moisture present then you
want to use different windows and
there's a large selection of those I'm
not going to go through all those here
but you can read up on those offline
liquid sample cells
there's dispersive infrared instruments
have rectangular apertures while Fourier
transform infrared instruments require
cells with circular apertures and you
don't want to mix the different types of
cells for the different instruments see
liquid cells have a fixed bad link and
the cell assembly is generally glued or
epoxied together the fixed path link
makes them ideal for quantitative
analysis demountable liquid cells means
you can take them apart and put them
back together again and they're usually
easier to clean as a result we can use
them for qualitative analysis as well as
quantitative analysis because we have a
variety of spacers that can be used to
change the cell path length you just
want to make sure you use the same
spacer time after time as various
there's numerous window materials that
can be used and we should only use
water-soluble windows with organic
solvents and samples because any contact
with water will start to significantly
decrease spectral quality because of
fogging of the windows water inside the
windows are useful for almost any liquid
sample budget can be restrictions in the
spectral range so this was the side
I was thinking about here's the salt
windows and you can see the range from
40,000 to 33,000 somewhere near all the
way down around 400 650 in a case of
sodium fluoride and we go to the water
insoluble windows we have quartz calcium
fluoride calcium fluoride but see we're
starting to lose some sensitivity
because um or spectral range because of
the cut-offs that occur in active areas
of the infrared spectrum so quartz
calcium fluoride and barium fluoride are
going to reduce the effectiveness of the
technique because we're going to lose a
good proportion or a good portion of the
emit infrared spectrum ks5 we want to be
a little bit careful because in stallion
bromide iodide which is not very good
for you
um so you don't want to lick the window
or something goofy like that and
encourage you to have those polished
professionally or if they get bent or
broken to simply throw them out because
they are not really good for you don't
want to get exposed to that iam silver
chloride and silver bromide are fairly
frequently used but they're also UV
sensitive and they can darken if they're
left in the Sun same selenite in zinc
sulphide are pretty good solid windows
they have good sensitivity good
throughput they are a little bit fragile
but as you can see the range of them is
perfect for men and Fred and then
there's an example of diamond we're
going to talk about diamond a little bit
later when we talk about some of the
other accessories so here we're very
concerned about the path length of the
of the liquid cells because as you can
see there's a very big difference for
instance hexane here is in a point 0 to
5 millimeter cell and we get a very good
spectrum when we try and look at hexanol
in a point zero one five millimeter cell
that's 15 microns on thickness between
the two windows we see that we're over
absorbing the OS and the CH stretches
are way off scale as well as the CH and
O H bending modes so we want to make
that cell even thinner
usually on the order of 0.01 point zero
one two point zero zero five or ten and
five microns so here's an example of a
capillary film spectrum where we just
put a few drops of benzo nitrile again
between two salt windows I can do that
because I know benzo nitrile is not
going to attack the salt windows and we
get a very good spectrum again the
baseline zero is zero
sorry near 100% transmission and the
strongest peak is right about 15% tea
plants using another example here is
isopropanol again a few drops of the
alcohol between the two windows and we
see a very good spectrum again the
baseline is near 100% tea the strongest
peak is right about 20 percent which is
fine for this qualitative spectrum we're
not doing quantitative analysis here so
Cass films is when we dissolve something
like a polymer in a solvent place the
solution onto a cell window and
evaporate the solvent lots of different
ways we can evaporate the solvent one is
by putting it in the hood allowing the
solvent to dry or you can gently one
with a hot plate to promote evaporation
but on very low heat for the talent
paper towel under the window to prevent
rapid heating and a slumping baseline or
band distortion can indicate large
particles in the casting or a sample
that is not completely cover the sample
beat so here's an example of the cast
film of resin dissolved in benzene and
we collect a spectrum of the solvent
itself so we can make sure that if there
are any interfering piece marked with an
X in this view we know they belong to
the benzene and not to the cast film of
the resident another thing john sample
here is polyethylene that was cast in
the film and it's approximately 1/2
and you see it's a little bit thicker
than we really should have because the
bottom Peaks for the see the bottom of
the piece with the CH stretching modes
are touching 0% transmission but it
still gives us a good quality spectrum
so now when you talked about
transmission we'll move on to the
reflection techniques reflection
techniques of what probably most people
are familiar with ATR attenuated total
reflection is that little device where
you put your sample on the crystal put
pressure on it and we collect a spectrum
diffuse reflectance is looking at
powders in a little sample cup the
powders are actually mixed with
potassium bromide to give it kind of a
medium background or a moderate
background and then we collect the
spectrum regular reflection is or a
specular reflection is where we're doing
an angle of incidence around 15 to 30
degrees so that the angle of the
incidence to the the pink area on the
sample is about 30 degrees and gravy and
reflectance is where we change the
angles of the incidence and collection
so that we're just raising the surface
of the sample and we use this at
extremely thin layers so we can actually
use polarization sometimes to enhance
our sensitivity so each of these
techniques has its place in the
laboratory we're going to go through
them one by one so reflectance
accessories and methods are designed to
provide analysis for cap capability from
lots of samples that are difficult to
prepare for transmission spectra or for
reliability or speed of collection we
use these accessories so reflection
accessories methods provide analysis for
powders solids and thick coatings that
can be analyzed with diffuse reflectance
flat surfaces and thin coatings can be
analyzed using specular and grazing
angle accessories and multiple internal
reflection accessories allows sampling
of almost every existing sample type
except gases what we can do so
powders and liquids with an H er and
collect a very good spectrum there's
things we have to be aware of when we're
looking collecting these spectra using
these accessories to collect spectra and
we've got to be careful on the
interpretation of the data because there
can be some changes associated with
associated with the absorption spectrum
compared to the transmission data so
while the standard transmission methods
are one that recognize sometimes it's
absolutely impossible to prepare a
sample for a collection using
transmission reflectance methods often
require a little sample prep and can't
provide a universal sample interface
they're often simply used and in many
cases very easy to clean and maintain
and we have qualitative and limited
qualitative analysis or routinely
perform the reason we say limited
qualitative analysis is sometimes you
don't have quite the range of
sensitivity the range of concentrations
that you do when you do transmission
sampling some disadvantages for
reflectance can often produce spectra
they can require mathematical courage
and if you don't know that you may not
see the spectrum in the same way and if
you did it by transmission can
significantly reduce an instrument
energy throughput and will often require
more scans to get a good SNR value we
have to make sure that we have the
optical alignment set up properly and
we'll talk about that as we go through
this and we need to check that on a
regular basis we often have limited
sensitivity to minor component
concentrations or extremely large
concentrations they can't be more
expensive compared to things like liquid
cells or KBR pellets sometimes there's a
limited spectral range and we generally
need to use them with Fourier transform
infrared instruments or FTIR so the
first one we're going to talk about is
diffuse reflectance or drifts diffuse
reflectance accessories focus the
incoming mean that first mirror in the
a picture here in the figure where it
bounces up to a very large collection
object and that collection optic is
round and has a surface all the way
around that sample cup so that the light
coming off the surface of that sample
cup is collected then direct it down to
the last mirror in the assembly and onto
the detector we often run a blank using
KBR or some other substrate and we'll
talk about some of those examples as we
go through the rest of the presentation
excuse me so specular reflectance um and
this is a diagram of what's actually
occurring so when the light comes into
the sample it hits the top surface of
the sample and it's bounced off right
off the top of the surface
that's called specular reflectance and
often there's a block or a hole in that
collection here to make sure that the
specular component is automatically
rejected the other two beams some of
them are going through the sample which
is the little white particles the KBR
matrix is the black particles and
they're reflected or transmitted through
that the powder sample the white and
then bounce off of the some of the
potassium bromide and I'm collected by
the mirror and brought to the detective
some of the light beams travel all the
way down to the bottom of the cup and
never to come back out again so there's
a lot of light losses here um when you
compare the throughput of a drifts
accessory to an instrument the drift
accessory is only going to provide
somewhere around five to ten percent of
the overall energy from the instrument
um as you compare before and after so
that's what we want to be careful with
diffuse reflectance because if we're
looking at extremely low concentrations
it may not have the sensitivity to do so
and we'll have to collect a lot of scans
something like a hundred twenty eight or
2:56 to get a good spectrum of the
sample so here's an example of diffuse
reflectance of a 1% fine a certain in
potassium bromide on and again you can
see there's some drift in the baseline
we're not at a hundred percent and
that's partially due to the loss of
light as that light goes down to the
bottom of the sample cup um we do have
it much stronger than that twenty
percent value twenty percent T value so
we've got a good spectrum overall one of
the things that's critical with diffuse
reflectance is that we properly tune the
sample cup every single time we collect
a spectrum so in this case we're looking
at the spectrum in the absorbance format
with the peaks pointing up these are
interchangeable percent T and absorbance
and in this case what we want to do is
make sure that D we there's often
adjustments on mirrors or the height of
the cup relative to collection optic and
so what we want to do is tune the sample
cup so that the spectrum of the sample
is right down near zero absorbance so
when we convert it to percent
transmission it will look much like our
standard spectrum with the 100 percent
the base on and on a percent
transmission and the peak maximum ever
and around 22 to 25 percent T um this is
the correction that's used for diffuse
reflectance the cobalt among correction
or km mom it's pretty complex equation
but pretty much every instrument
software that I know has got the km
correction in its library of commands
and this is what happens when you do to
Belk among the first spectrum is before
km correction in the red trace ii
spectrum in the blue is after km
correction
and we can see how it sharpens up the
bands reduces the intensity a little bit
and basically corrects it for the
differences that occur between diffuse
reflectance in transmission so diffuse
reflectance of alternative applications
we can do analysis of a rough or
diffusely scattering surface for example
the surface of tablets or pills can be
roughen by using silicon carbide paper
that's basically wet/dry sandpaper
that's what it sternum it's four hundred
eight hundred grit and what we do is we
rub the surface of the tablet so that we
make the surface very rough and then we
put the sample in the drift accessory
and some of the drifts accessories
actually have a little holder for
tablets and pills another way we can use
diffuse reflectance is for thick
coatings such as paints or polymer
finishes by scraping the surface with
that silicon carbide paper and then
analyzing the surface of the paper
infrared absorption occurs when light
strikes the surface of the particles on
the paper surface and what we do is we
collect a samples a background spectrum
excuse me from a clean silicon carbide
paper or pad and then we collect our
sample spectrum so there's a lot of
these commercially available and we can
get the pads that are self-adhesive so
they have a little spread a little
sample cup that has a flat surface so
the pan will stick right to the surface
of that so here's an example where we
use silicon carbide or diamond pans and
basically we took a computer cover which
is a painted surface as well as a cable
connector on some of the stuff is a
little bit old sorry but like your USB
cable that surface is a polymer and
we've rubbed the surface and gotten some
of the particles in train on the pad
surface and then put the pad in the
accessory to the like to spectrum the
same with the painted surface of the
computer cover
so the next section is specular and
reflection absorption and grazing angle
analysis these all use somewhat the same
concept where the sample is supported
above two mirrors with one beam coming
in the infrared beam coming in to the
first mirror being bounced up to the
surface of the sample the light bounces
right back down again to the second
mirror and over to the detector so in
the case of specular reflectance with a
very flat and shiny surface we can do
the incoming and outgoing infrared beams
at about 30 degrees so 30 to 35 degrees
where 90 degrees is parallel to the
sample surface lots of polymer sheets
sheets painted or coated metals glasses
or papers any flat coated surface is a
possibility for specular reflectance and
we can also then go on to in Frederick
reflection absorption is applied to
coatings on flat shiny surfaces so by
widening the angle of that so instead of
30 to 35 maybe 40 45 50 degrees um we
start to widen out the angles and get
more absorption from the surface area of
the sample that Bob then as the light
passes through the sample to the
background or the substrate as its term
which is very shiny then it bounces back
through the coating and by changing that
angle we can go as thin as monolayer
thicknesses and by going to the grazing
angle about 80 to 85 degrees we can
simply graze the surface of the sample
but we increase the path length of the
light as it goes through the sample
cream is cronic transform
is used to correct for the specular
reflection you can see that spectrum in
the red is before the Kremlin's chrony
and this is a poly methyl methacrylate
sample and you can see there's a lot of
derivative bands in it it looks pretty
messy but after we do the Kremlin's
grouting we remove the imaginary
specular component and calculate the
real absorption spectrum and you see a
good spectrum for methyl methacrylate
this doesn't always work but in the case
of a coated surface we did it on on that
as well
this is a coated paper collecting the
the sample with specular reflectance and
an after the KK transform we get a very
good looking spectrum in a percent T
format infrared reflection absorption we
have three different samples here where
we have we have taken the sample which
has a shiny substrate and there's a
polymer coating on the surface and one
of these is Polymathic poly methyl
methacrylate as opposed to the other one
that was a block of of PMMA this is
actually a thin coating on a shiny
substrate another example is silane
which is a silicon silicon oil and then
polystyrene in the final spectrum at the
bottom where this is a thin coating on
that shiny substrate and we're basically
setting up the accessory to collect the
the data from an incoming and outgoing
angle of about sixty degrees so as we
change the collection angle and the
incidence angle go from normal to
towards grazing you can see how the
intensity for that silane film gets it
stronger and stronger as we increase
that angle all the way from 30 degrees
to 75 degrees and if we were to plot
that
it would be almost a straight line so
the last section is multiple external
reflection also known as Mir or 8-yard
generated total reflectance so we're
gonna go into a little bit of theory
here sorry but um Snell's law predicts
that at a critical angle
light energy penetrating and crystalline
media with a refractive index greater
than air will reflect radiation along
the interior of the crystal excuse me
that is the light beam strikes the
interior surface of the crystal and
evanescent wave penetrates have defined
depth into a sample that's an intimate
contact with the crystal surface so we
see the sample in the blue pressed
against the surface of the crystal in
the yellow and every time the light
comes to the surface of that crystal
there's a little bit of light that goes
into the sample and we get an absorption
process and that's what we're trying to
get is that absorption process so that
we see in the final analysis a spectrum
now the mir mechanism only provides a
finite depth of penetration in as it's
in kind of the sample ISM sorry a finite
penetration into the sample as it's in
contact with the mir elements or crystal
for the majority of the Mir crystals the
depth of penetration is basically
limited to 1 to 8 microns depending upon
the wavelength so there's some things
that we want to take away from this one
is that the depth of penetration changes
as the wavelength changes so as we go
from 3000 wave numbers that about 1
micron penetration down to 500 wave
numbers where most of the body of the
information is located between 1,500 and
500 the depth of penetration now becomes
greater and greater all the way up to 8
microns what happens is we get a change
in intensity of the peak the relative
peak intensities
as we change the wavelength so there's
lots of different crystals used for Mir
in ETR zinc selenide is the most common
Kiera's v and germanium are some
alternatives we can also use diamond and
silicon um there's lots of different
configurations some have very specific
sampling needs
there's multi bounce crystals things
like that generally multiple internal
reflectance accessories or heme iron
accessories allow a sample to be placed
on both sides of the internal reflection
crystal mounted vertically in the
accessory so it stands up on and we put
sample on the other side HH ER or ATR
horizontal attenuated total reflectance
usually present only a single horizontal
surface so we can only access one side
of the crystal and get a sample analysis
although the technique is referred to
here as Mir and excuse me in practice
the terms HR and Mir are often
interchangeable so here's a listing of
the different crystal materials and
we're going to talk about diamond a
little bit because what we get is a
change or a rather we we have areas of
the spectrum where we're not supposed to
get any light um and we'll talk about
that in reference to a diamond har that
was developed and there now I'm readily
available
um and what happens is you can actually
get data in that 2500 to 16 minute area
just have to be careful how you do it
but one of the things to note off this
as well is the refractive index change
from 2.4 for zinc selenide all the way
up to 4.0 for germanium now how is that
relevant well remember this I don't have
the equation sorry um so the point is is
that when we look at germanium it has
some unique advantages as compared to
zinc selenide and we'll talk about that
in up in a later slide
but the point I wanted to make here is
that the equation for the depth of
penetration involves the refractive
index as well as the wavelength of light
that's involved with the Mir process so
we're talking about how the relative
peak intensities are distorted compared
to transmission spectra because the
wavelength gets longer and the depth of
penetration into the sample is greater
so what we see is for a polystyrene film
sample when we collect the HR spectrum
the peaks at 3,000 are really shortens
there they're not very intense as
compared to the transmission spectrum
for the same sample so we lose a lot of
information if we're not careful and we
don't recognize that this process is
occurring but we can actually do a
correction before ATR the ATR correction
and after the ATR correction to allow
for the change in the depth of
penetration as the wavelength changes in
the spectrum so what we're doing basic
is were enhancing the CH stretch region
at 3,000 and diminishing the CH band and
CH and the CC bends down below 1,500 um
so this is important because if we're
trying to compare an ATR spectrum to a
transmission library we will often get
incorrect values for the Equality Index
or hqi that we're looking for when we're
doing a library search
so we've either got to collect the
library or get the library in an HR
format if we're going to use an
eight-yard sampling accessory or we do
the ATR correction after we collect the
ATR spectrum and use the transmission
library but be aware that we may not get
complete correction of the ATR or mir
spectrum when using that command in our
software
so here we have a case where we're going
to need to go the germanium so we have
this carbon black filled polymer carbon
black is extremely absorbing and so with
the greater depth of penetration for
zinc solid I were actually getting too
much absorption and it's distorting the
spectrum when we move to the germanium
crystal however the depth of penetration
is much much shorter on the order of
about 0.5 microns to 2 microns and so we
get a much better spectrum that looks
somewhat more like a transmission
spectrum as we've collected for that
particular sample so microwaves are
accessories especially diamond can be
used to examine lots of different types
of samples because it's a small crystal
element on the order of about two
millimeters in diameter or a little bit
larger and we can use much higher
pressures and get a much better contact
between the sample and the crystal
surface so this accessory is often sold
with the instrument and turn a universal
sampling accessory so here's an example
excuse me of a methanol spectrum
collected using the diamond ATR and you
can see we've lost no information here
in that dead region from 1600 to 2500
that we saw in that one slide concerning
spectral ranges another example is
battery acid
now you wouldn't do battery acid on a
regular sample window or ATR crystal
because it would just eat it alive but
we can do it with diamond because
diamond is pretty much impervious to any
kind of sample even the extremely low pH
of battery acid on your number 1 or 1.5
which ordinarily would eat every window
up in seconds the diamond is actually
impervious to this and we get a very
good spectrum of the sample what
any loss of data and we clean the
battery acid off being careful not to
touch it with our fingers and we get a
good spectrum and we clean the accessory
off and go on to other samples like this
one where we took some polyethylene
terephthalate fibers from a car a
vehicle and we collected a spectrum
using the diamond accessory and we got a
very nice clean spectrum of those fibers
another example is nylon fibers and this
is the carpet from the same autumn um
and we can we get a which is taking a
few fibers places bonding it on to the
ATR accessories put the clam down to
collect to make sure that there's nice
high pressure of the sample surface
against the crystal surface and we get a
good spectrum so conclusions
transmission spectrum provide the
highest sensitivity and best detection
levels for all infrared sampling
techniques but sometimes we require some
extensive sample prep reflectance
accessories can be the most expedient
analysis method but there may be some
things we need to be aware of it is
important to always clean the
accessories and tools
immediately after analysis and always
verify the instrument and accessory
performance before use to ensure the
optimum results okay and that's our last
slide
Thank You dr. Larson for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
we'll address some of the most commonly
asked questions by our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box it
appears on your screen and click the
send button our speaker will follow up
with your questions via email so let's
get started our first question is does
the ATR method of analysis have any
disadvantages thanks Julie yeah that's a
good question because we kind of touched
on it in the presentation we just have
to be very careful in comparing the data
collected with the ATR some data
collected from some of them with it now
if I compare one each I respect another
HR spectrum we won't see a whole lot of
difference there but if we're trying to
compare it to diffuse reflectance or a
transmission spectrum we may see some
differences in the relative intensity
peak values and that could be a little
bit confusing also there can be some
slight peak shifts using the ATR
technique but again as long as you're
aware of those things you should be fine
going forward thank you
well were you done with our yes great
okay your next one is how do I verify
the performance of the accessory or
analysis method used a lot of times what
we'll do is we'll take some standard
sample that we know what the results
should be we run that sample using the
accessory or the analysis method and
make sure that we're getting the proper
data if we don't see the valid data that
we're expecting that we need to
investigate whether the accessory is
faulty like say it's not properly
aligned or maybe it's not tuned properly
um maybe our potassium bromide for
diffuse reflectance is wet or perhaps
for a KBR pellet it's wet on we need to
look at those things before we start
running regular scene
and a lot of times these checks are just
a few maybe a minute or two before we
start collecting data for the day we
just want to know from that point
forward going on that the data we're
collecting with the method or with the
accessory is going to be valid that it's
good that we've got everything the way
we should have thank you next one is do
you recommend any particular analysis
method oh boy that's a tricky one um a
lot of it depends on what you're trying
to do I mean for qualitative analysis
where I just need to know what the
material is the HTR accessory is
probably the easiest most versatile
method an accessory to do this um but if
I'm trying to do quantitative analysis
and I'm trying to do a very wide range
of quantitation well you might want to
go to one of the transmission methods
because it's gonna have a lot more
flexibility for quantitative analysis
and can accommodate a much wider
detection range then say the ATR method
or some of the other reflectance methods
the other side of that is let's say that
my sample is something that's very shiny
has a very thin surface or very thin
coating on a shiny surface
well then ATR transmission is not going
to work so we have to evaluate just what
the sample is and what the final answer
we're trying to obtain and that will
help make some decisions as far as what
accessory what method we should use
thank you for that looks like we have
time for one more question how do I
verify the instrument performance for
the accessory or analysis method that's
kind of similar to the one I caught
earlier but it's very similar a lot of
times that we remove the accessory from
the bench from the instrument and we
make sure that the instruments working
properly a lot of times we can monitor
the energy or the interferogram energy
um there's ways to do that into an
instrument and a lot of times we just
the dichotomy no and look at that but I
really do recommend that every single
morning or every day that we use the
instrument you don't know what the last
person did with the instrument so you
just want to make sure that it's
performing the way you wanted to then
you put the accessory and make sure it's
getting the same data or the same energy
value that you got last line because
you're gonna write all this down in your
notebook and that way you know when you
use the instrument it's working to your
satisfaction and you've got the data and
the information so if somebody ever
questions the results that you would
take you say look I verified in the
morning or in that day that the data I'm
going to get from this accessory or this
instrument is going to perform like it
did the last time I use it because I'm
looking at the values of my notebook and
I'm getting the same information time
after time after time
that's your reassurance that you're
getting complete quality optimum data
every time you use the instrument thank
you I would like to once again thank dr.
Larson for his presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through January
25th 2019 you'll receive an email from
laborat so when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that is
all for now thank you for joining us we
hope to see you again soon bye